I'd like to welcome
everyone to this morning
to Yale's fourth
annual Day of Data.
We're very happy to
have everyone here.
My name is Jill Parchuck.
I'm the Associate University
Librarian for Science,
Social Science, and Medicine.
And I'll be your
host for the morning.
Before we do anything,
I want to just give
a few little logistics.
There will be photos and video
being taken throughout the day,
so that you're aware of that
and give a little courtesy
to the photographers
while things are going on.
We ask you to silence
your cell phones.
I know everybody's
very important,
has a million things
going on, but we
can turn off the ringers.
Coffee you've already
seen, I hope, downstairs.
Lunch will be in the same
location this afternoon.
And we'll have some
instructions for you
at that point about how to
line up, queue up, to get down
to lunch so that we
don't have a mob scene.
Restrooms.
There are two
restrooms right down
the corridor right
near where you came in,
and then there are a
few more down stairs.
If you just go down the stairs,
and down the hallway, and down
another set of stairs.
The schedule for the
day is on the web,
but we also had some we
handed out at the table
as you came in.
So if you need a schedule,
you can pick one up there.
First thing I'd like
to say is thank you
to all the sponsors
for the Day of Data.
First off the Office
of the Provost,
who has been generous and very
supportive in hosting this.
The Center for Science
and Social Science
Information, many staff members
who helped to make the day
happen.
The Center for
Teaching and Learning,
who is supporting our
video set up for the day.
The Digital Humanities
Lab, who also
heavily participated
in the planning.
The Institution for
Social and Policy Studies,
who's been a great supporter of
Day of Data from the beginning
and did a lot of
the planning, also.
The Yale Institution for
Network Science, also
big contributors to this event.
And Sigma XI
Distinguished Visitor Fund
is also supportive, so we're
very grateful for our sponsors.
A big thank you, also,
to the planning committee
for the Day of Data, which
has been superbly led
by Michelle Hudson.
Michelle actually deserves
a hand of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Other members of that committee
have been Kayleigh
Bohemier Cathy
DeRose, Erin Wachowicz
Melanie Maksin,
Themba Flowers, Paul
DiBello -- we couldn't have
done it without Paul--
Kate  Nyhan,
Peter Peduzzi, Limor Peer,
and George Stranz.
So thank you to all of you.
One thing I think you
all might like to know
is that the Day of Data
also holds some follow up
events in the spring.
This year in line with
the Day of Data theme
of reproducibility, we'll be
having a spring reproducibility
workshop that will be conducted
by the Center for Open Science.
And that'll be
held on March 3rd.
So we're really looking
forward to that.
There will also be a
series of other smaller
lectures in the spring.
And they've been outstanding
in the past, as well.
So that information
will be sent out
to everybody who
registered for today.
Onto our outstanding
schedule of speakers.
Our first speaker
this morning is
Steve Girvin, Deputy Provost for
Research, and Eugene Higgins,
Professor of Physics.
Professor Girvin
joined the Yale faculty
in 2001 as a professor
of physics, and in 2007
was named Deputy
Provost for Research.
His portfolio includes
the Central Campus Science
Departments, the School of
Forestry and Environmental
Studies, and the School
of Engineering and Applied
Science, as well as various
institutes and initiatives.
Additionally he collaborates
on science strategy
with the School of Medicine.
His academic research is in
the area of theoretical quantum
physics.
Steve, do you sleep?
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
Professor Girvin holds
a bachelor's degree
from Bates College,
a master's degree
from the University of
Maine, and MS and Ph
degrees from Princeton.
In recognition of his research
and contributions in the field,
Professor Girvin has been
elected to the American
Association for the
Advancement of Science,
the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences,
and the US National
Academy of Sciences.
In 2007 he was awarded
the Oliver E. Buckley
prize of the American
Physical Society.
Without further
ado, Steve Girvin.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm hooked up to my--
one of my various science ties.
Today's astronomy.
[LAUGHTER]
So and this-- is only going
to display on that screen.
Is that right?
So welcome.
And welcome to this
fabulous new space
that you'll be hearing more
about as the home of the Yale
Center for Research Computing.
Is this you?
Second one.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
So I don't have to talk
to this crowd about the--
in this modern era, the flood
of data, the deluge of data,
the tsunami of data which
is coming in to Yale
every day from all
parts of the world.
You genomics people are
the worst offenders.
You know who you are.
[LAUGHTER]
But here's another
source of data that
flows in to Yale every day.
Anybody recognize this?
This is the South Pole.
We're standing 10,000
feet above sea level.
There's 10,000-- this
is snow on the surface.
But below there is 10,000 feet
of solid ice, crystal clear.
Light can travel through
it huge distances.
And there are lots and lots of
photomultiplier detectors where
they melted a hole
thousands of feet down,
buried them in the ice,
and trillions and trillions
of neutrinos from the
galaxy are passing
through every square centimeter
of that space every second.
And occasionally one of
them interacts with the ice
and gives off a bit of light.
And the entire
Antarctic ice shelf
is being used as a massive
detector, which is then
detecting these particles from
the Sun, and from the galaxy,
and from supernovas.
Amazing and weird source
of data which flows
into the university each day.
And of course there are many,
many bigger sources than that.
We're-- cryo-electron microscopy
is about to start on the west
campus.
That will be attempting to catch
up with the genomics people,
but the genomics people will
probably still win that race.
So many of you--
the locals will have
seen President Salovey's
communication to the
university 10 days ago
about the university priorities
and academic investments that
will be made over the next
10 to 15 years at Yale.
And while there is
a bit of something
in there for everybody, the far
and away the key top priority
is going to be science.
It's the-- it's the
area that we need
to focus in to compete
on the world stage
with the other really top
universities around the world.
And so of course our
ability to handle data
and do great science is going
to be a key part of that.
And we have to work on
the infrastructure needed
to do that.
You see here a rendering
of the new multi-hundred,
million dollar science building
primarily devoted to biology.
It's in place of
the Gibbs building,
which doesn't look
as nice as this.
[LAUGHS]
And the-- there will be space
for cryo-electron microscopy,
optical microscopy, all
kinds of biology labs,
physics and astronomy labs.
All of which are going to be
producing more and more data.
So on data-- of course
ties in with Yale
fulfilling its mission.
We are an institution
that take our mission
to do good in the
world very seriously.
We're trying to
improve the world
through education, research,
practice, clinical practice,
educate leaders.
And free exchange of ideas is
absolutely a core principle.
And there-- that is
now including data.
So in exchange for
the opportunity
to do research and
fulfill Yale's mission,
people have academic freedom
to choose the topics that they
work on, but have
some responsibilities
to steward the scholarly
record, to provide access
to the knowledge that
they're generating.
And of course responsible
for making sure
that it's reproducible, and
for allowing other people
to check the reproducibility
of that data.
And that's, in this day and
age, a super important topic.
It gets complicated
when you think
about the sort of traditional--
the tradition of keeping
your raw data.
I hate to keep picking
on the genomics people,
but that's just becoming
a physical impossibility
in some cases.
And you have to decide what
are the standards of the field
going to be in terms
of registering data,
and what fraction of the--
what version of the non-raw
data, et cetera, et cetera.
So it's some
complicated questions
as the ethos and different
subfields evolves.
There are a lot of demands and
expectations from many sources.
The government is
here to help us, and--
or was.
[LAUGHTER]
There's been a-- there's been
a requirement for about nine
years now that clinical trials
should be in-- the results--
summaries of the results should
be available to the public.
And they should be
registered before you start,
and the results summarized
when you're done.
That enforcement
has not been strong,
but starting January 18th
it's going to be very strong.
And we have to be prepared
and have systems in place
to with the Institutional Review
Boards, et cetera, et cetera,
to make sure that happens.
Everybody knows that OSTP
has been promulgating
policies about open access to
data, so have the journals.
And there's various
reproducibility initiatives
which are exposing potential
weaknesses in certain areas
of certain fields of research.
And I think it's very important
that we support those.
And if we lose the
trust of the public
because our results
are not reproducible
or appear to have been
influenced in some way
inappropriately, it's
just all over for science.
So we absolutely have to
support those initiatives.
So we've been thinking
about this here,
and I've been getting a lot
of help from Limor Peer,
who's sitting over here, and
who helped organize this event.
Thank you, Limor.
Thinking about policies
and guidelines, services
and centers that Yale has
now, or should have now,
and education and training--
not just for the young
people, but also for faculty
who are beginning
to see the tsunami
data coming towards them.
So Limor has been chairing the
Research Data Policy Committee.
And we've been trying to think
about as part of the, kind of,
infrastructure for supporting
data and data science at Yale
and sharing of data,
we need not just
physical infrastructure
but policies in place.
And we're going to be,
in the coming months,
on little roadshows
to various departments
and divisions around
the university talking
about that work
that's been going on,
which includes some sort
of little white papers
that we'll talk about.
Principles that we
should keep in mind
as we develop further
policies as we build
our infrastructure,
and hardware,
and consulting services,
and all those things.
Also new at the university is
a Data Governance Committee,
which is primarily
focused on Yale's
internal administrative data,
classroom occupancy, registrar
data, financial data, all
kinds of things like that.
You know to clarify
who has access
to what, how much
is public, just
all kinds of policy questions.
That and attempts to define
very precisely where is
the primary record kept.
And please don't keep
inaccurate copies of that.
Keep a link to that
primary one and we'll
be able to function more
efficiently, we hope.
So it's primarily
about administration.
We have a number of
services and centers
already in existence-- the
Research Data Consultation
Group.
On this side of town there's
a stat lab in the CSSSI,
that Jill can tell you about.
In the Institute-- ISPS--
ISPS, Institution for
Social and Policy Studies.
This is the other
half of Limor's life.
They're pretty
serious about keeping
records that have been--
can still be accessed
and understood
after you've written them.
You'll hear more, I think,
from Harlan Krumholz today.
He's been involved with this
project in the med school.
And there's-- for clinical
trials and big data things
in the med school, there's
this data coordinating center.
So there are many
places around campus
where education and training
in data science are--
exist or are coming
into existence.
We have a 2 and 1/2
year old Yale Institute
for Network Science,
which is bringing together
people interested in
networks-- social networks,
gene regulation networks,
ethernet networks,
every possible thing
you can imagine.
It's probably the most
heterogeneous group
of people that are willing to
talk to each other on campus.
And it's because they
can all come and learn,
if they don't know it already,
the language of mathematics
for describing networks.
And of course big
data is part of that.
It will-- assuming it is
approved by the corporation
in this coming week--
there will be a Data
Science Initiative
announced involving--
in the FAS involving the
Department of Statistics,
Computer Science,
other mathematics
departments on campus.
And was recently
announced a Yale Center
for Biomedical Data Science.
And one of my jobs is to
get these two coordinated
and talking to each other.
The Digital Humanities
Lab is another place
where our humanist friends can
come and learn about numbers
and other inhuman objects.
The Stat Lab-- this Yale
Center for Research Computing
you'll hear much more about
in the next talk from Karen.
And there are a lot of data
hackathons going on, both from
the-- organized from the
top down, and a lot from--
like Hack Yale--
from the bottom up.
Just students getting
together and having
an event with
thousands of people
from around the world showing
up to spend the weekend working
on data.
So this is intended
to not be readable.
Just to illustrate the scale
of things that we either have
or need to have in
the coming future
in order to manage the
whole data lifecycle,
and for those parts of
it-- the research that
are externally funded.
They're kind of the pre-award,
award, and post-award parts.
And some of these
things are in place.
Many more need to be worked on.
And so we have a-- we have
a big challenge ahead of us.
And we'll be coming to
talk to the Yale folks
in this room about
how we can make the--
build the appropriate services,
infrastructure, policies,
procedures to deal with
this flood of data,
which is such an essential
part of research today.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]